We look at just two simple sets in this video.
Set 'P' which has one, two and three as its elements,
and set 'Q' which has one, two,
three, four, and five as its elements.
Understand the elements well.
This has one, two and three
and this one has one, two, three, four and five.
This is a part of this.
And that’s why we say set 'P' is a part of set 'Q'.
And we learned in the previous video,
that 'part of' also means subsets.
So we can say that set 'P' is a subset of set 'Q'.
Do we have a symbol to represent this?
Yes, it's written like this.
'P' is a subset of 'Q'.
The letter 'U' is sleeping on this line.
So when is 'P' a subset of a 'Q'?
Set 'P' is a subset of set 'Q'
when every element in 'P' is also present in 'Q'.
Look at the elements.
Every element in 'P' is also present in 'Q'.
But this statement raises a new query.
Look at sets 'C' and 'D'.
Set 'C' has four, five and six, as its elements.
And set 'D' has four, six and five as its elements.
Both the sets have the same elements which makes them equal.
But every element in set 'C' is also present in set 'D'.
Based on the definition we can say that set 'C' is a subset of set 'D'.
This also tells us something more!
It tells us that every set is a subset of itself.
'P' is a subset of 'P'.
'Q' is a subset of 'Q'. And so on...
For some reason, this does not seem entirely correct
and that give rise to a new concept of proper subset.
Look at sets 'P' and 'Q'.
Set 'P' is a part of set 'Q'
but there is at least one element in set 'Q' which is not present
and in set 'P'.
We say that set 'P' is a proper subset of set 'Q'.
This sign indicates proper subset.
And this tells us that all elements of 'P' are present in set 'Q',
but there is at least one element in 'Q'
Which is not present in 'P'.
We can see that 4 and 5 are not present in 'P'.
So that's the concept of a proper subset.
Sometimes it is also referred to as the strict subset.
Can we say 'C' is a proper subset of 'D'?
Think about it,
that would be incorrect since there is no element in 'D',
which is not a part of 'C'.
There has to be at least one such element.
That's the only difference between a subset,
and a proper subset.
Just one last thing we need to understand.
Just as we say 'P' is a proper subset of 'Q'.
We can also say that set 'Q' is a super set of set 'P'.
This symbol is used to represent super set.